in this video we'll walk through how to
provide your users the ability to
upgrade their subscriptions and what
that process looks like behind the
scenes if the user is trying to access a
feature that requires a more expensive
subscription you'll want to have a way
for them to upgrade their current
subscription when your app starts call
start connection in the google play
billing library once the connection is
complete you will also need to call
query purchases in order to handle
existing purchases make sure to override
on purchases updated in order to handle
any future purchases that complete while
your app is open each of your
subscription products has a unique SKU
to change from one product to another
you just need the SKU for the existing
subscription product and the SKU for the
new subscription product to perform an
upgrade launch the purchase flow with
the Google Play billing library using
the parameter set old SKU replace the
old SKU with the upgrade SKU by using
the billing flow params builder set old
SKU and set SKU enter the new upgraded
SKU in the set SKU field and Google Play
will take care of any additional payment
needed it's important to note that you
can set the proration mode here as well
check the documentation for more
information Google Play will send you a
new purchase token through the billing
library and that purchase token will
follow the same steps outlined in our
video understanding purchase flow your
app registers the new token with your
back-end servers and sends it to the
Google Play Developer API for
verification but there is one important
difference here from first-time
subscription purchases this time Google
Play Developer API will return a linked
purchase token filled in the
subscription response
be sure to invalidate the token provided
in the linked purchase token to make
sure that the old token is not used to
get access to your services your server
will store this updated information and
let the app know the users subscription
has been successfully upgraded you can
follow the same process to provide your
users with a subscription downgrade
option which you can make available in
the settings section of your app
for more information visit the link on
screen or check out our other videos